la vulgarisation c'est ça s'apprend sur
le tas je crois pas qu'on puisse le
faire par un enseignement je crois que
on on le fait souvent on s'aperçoit de
ce qui marche pas on
améliore bonjour comment allez-vous ce
matin nous nous sommes heureux de vous
retrouver il est 7h nous sommes dimanche
comme chaque weekend thé ou café avec un
invité que nous aimons particulièrement
et particulièrement sur France 2 c'est
uber riz ubert Riv bonjour bonjour je
disais particulièrement sur France 2
parce que nous vous retrouvons chaque
une fois par par an au mois d'août pour
la la nuit des étoiles
filant depuis 6 ans oui et cette année
c'était dans le gerse c'était un grand
moment alors je rappelle pour ceux qui
ne vous connaîtrait pas mais à mon avis
il y en a très peu astrophysicien vous
êtes professeur aussi d'université vous
êtes écrivain vous êtes à savant et
j'aime le mot pour vous définir poète
vous l'acceptez oui je suis ravi
j'aurais jamais cru qu'on maurait collé
ce mot mais je suis très content pour
moi c'est vraiment quelque chose deable
poète poète dans vos propos pe être dans
vos pensées pe être aussi dans votre
physique par votre physique c'est vrai
cette barbe blanche ses yeux clair bon
et puis cet accent québécois qui nous
vient de Montréal où vous êtes né c'est
ça il déjà quelques années de cela avec
un père qui qui aimait en fait la qui
qui était la aimait la nature mais qui
n'était pas lui-même du tout dans dans
ce milieu-là non pas du tout il était
représentant de commerce oui et mais mon
père et ma mère aimaient beaucoup la
nature et nous l'ont fait aimer j'ai
nous étions quatre dans la famille et
tout je me souviens comment ma mère
admirait les couchés de soleil ou les
oiseaux elle avait une véritable
vénération pour la nature et évidemment
c'est communicatif c'est contagieux ce
que les parents aiment les enfants ont
tendance à à le valoriser aussi donc
pour moi ça a certainement joué un rôle
important est-ce que vous avez réussi à
transmettre à vos quatre enfants le même
goût pour la nature je crois je crois
que ils ont tous beaucoup de goût pour
la nature effectivement vulgarisation on
parle beaucoup de de ce mot-là quand on
évoque uberif est-ce que c'était aussi
un mot qui vous plaît ou qui vous déplaî
on m'a dit qu'en anglais ça avait un
sens très négatif j'ai l' employé
l'autre jour dans ne dites jamais ça
c'est V vulgaire ouis péjoratif en
français bon c'est pas le meilleur mot
mais je crois pas qu'il a cette
connotation très négative moi j'aimer
j'aime mieux diffusion des connaissances
par exemple je trouve ça plus approprié
al vulgarisation ou alors diffusion des
connaissances c'est un talent inné chez
vous ou c'est une démarche
personnelle c'est quelque chose qui m'a
surpris moi-même je me destinais pas du
tout à être un vulgarisateur je faisais
une carrière de physicien nucléaire avec
des sujets très pointus dessus et des
amis quelquefois m'ont demandé
d'expliquer ce que je faisais et je me
suis aperçu très vite que ils aimaient
beaucoup m'entendre parler de cela
pardon il' ils en redemandaient et puis
à un moment donné j'ai commencé on m'a
demandé de faire des des exposé de de
mon métier alors j'apportais les
diapositives astronomiques et je parlais
et puis j'ai eu un un retour extrêmement
positif des gens m'ont dit mais pourquoi
tu écris pas euh ces choses-là personne
ne nous parle cela alors j'ai écris mes
livres et puis là bien évidemment ça
fait boule de neige parce que si vos
livres marchent bien on vous demande de
faire des conférences faire des
conférences et puis la vulgarisation
c'est ça sprend sur le T je cux pas
qu'on puisse le faire par un
enseignement je crois que on on le fait
souvent on s'aperçoit de ce qui marche
pas on améliore la réaction avec les
gens est très importante aussi les gens
viennent me voir et ils me disent ah ben
là j'ai pas compris alors j'essaie de
reprendre ah ben comme si tu le dis
comme ça plus simpleou ou des images
c'est très souvent trouver les bonnes
images les gens disent ah si tu le si
c'est ils me disent là je comprends si
tu l'expliques comme ça donc au cours
des années évidemment on prend du
[Musique]
métier